quanti sono
ora sono gli hotel
berruti solida stare immersi nuova
storia paurosi guardate bene in queste
immagini si intravede chi dovremo
affrontare oggi è una sorta di
animatronic personaggio un po
indemoniato animatronics lo scopriremo
assieme l'avete trovato e invece noi
siamo quelli seduti per terra che stanno
piangendo
sappiamo niente di questo gioco sono
solo che vi piace un sacco piace un
sacco perché super popolare quindi
mettetevi comodi preti poke orme
lasciate unica centro
[Musica]
tre
rate scadute sostituirsi lì pronti via
ecco si fa c'è scritto trova le chiavi
prescritti prima che sia troppo tardi
siamo pelati siamo dei bambini i bambini
piccoli occhio tipo in un asilo ma un
bambino non si riesce solido ma neanche
questo ok troviamo le chiavi per uscire
ma prima che ricercano vi abbiamo detto
il nome il nome dell'anima tronic
orsacchiotto indemoniato che c'era eddy
si chiama the bay ma qui vi ho già fuori
edito da chi avendo visto l'ultima
fiamma ti ho preso non ci credo stanno
sopravvissuta 26 cura vediamo ora
vediamo dal punto di non prevedere
appreso le altre di b giuliano mi hanno
capitolo 1 teddy
devo andare ora divertirmi
ti prego non lasciarmi tornerò presto
vai a giocare con quell orsacchiotto ma
che si
mamma ha chiuso
quindi quella sarebbe mia madre mi ha
lasciato da solo dopo questa ghiotta
scappa testa tra preti non si capisce
se la chiamata sopra no no devo dobbiamo
trovare una chiave ma non riesco neanche
a saltare in alto perché sono un bambino
allora io e seguirò per quanti siamo
rimasti
in 4 sarà molto facile trovare tutte
queste chiavi da sola sembrati punto
pighi è vero ecco qua qualcuno una
chiave
attenta attenta lista di resterebbe che
sto dicendo
scappa scappa
ma che strane i suoi passi si fa
qualcuno è una chiave prova inseguire se
sì se vai vai vai e dietro di me è vero
se il protocollo dice che cosa ha preso
sia dietro di te mio francesco ok stiamo
riprovando l'obiettivo è trovare quella
chiave nero per uscire da per salvare
dall'orso produttivo prima trovare tutte
le chiavi una ragazza già una chiave
davvero queste la seco
wow lo ha seguito
la vita stories dove stai andando quasi
vuole una chiave dorata bertola l'isola
chunlei questo qui c'è lo stesso peso
ok seguiamo quello vuole chiamare viola
che sanchez e se li seguiamo senza
prendere mai sto continuando facile
aiutare per darlo
io strisciano per il resto del tempo
striscio seguendo questa con la chiave
è affrettato a dire che vada mai chiuso
la porta così eccolo porto che succede
perché non si mostri non si è mosso vi
ho mai visto e bloccatori qualcuno ha
fatto qualcosa per l'ottimo allora
tantissimo ma cos'è questa muove
nell'aria si sente infatti
ecco questo nokia vedere seguiamo forse
riusciamo a far parte così
ieri sta seguendo
aiuta lui deve aprite aprite e ancora e
ancora bull pulsante rosso qui si può
fare niente 72 la che vedere lui può
osservarsi forte
alla saba e
se riuscirà a rischio pare non fanno
niente da fare niente derivato immobili
alla porta
bene siccome vitale riuscito a scappare
perché si è fatta prima porno
passiamo al capitolo ii titolo in realtà
a quattro capitoli se volete vederli
tutti mi raccomando lasciate un mi piace
qua sotto vediamo se i voti sono
abbastanza prendere il capitolo 2 nome
ma che torniamo al capitolo 1 ok questa
volta proprio nella pa regolare capito
se possiamo andare al capitolo 2 anche
se non mi ricordo un bel niente vino
vero va bene erano le chiavi una la
chiave gialla la seguendo inseguendo noi
ti volevo solo dire questo tipo
ma per per prenderci seguire allora è
compreso un buio che come un giusto che
la chiave di voi che cos'è che cosa è
successo annunciato la macchinetta e
così
magica
per dire che gli altri giocatori hanno
scelto la versione incubo
non so cosa voglia dire ha visto
cancellare subito adesso facciamo da
spettatore almeno sottoscriviamo di più
forse la persona incubo vuol dire che ci
sono
quanti sono
forse sono solo dei cloni tipo vedi ma
tanti sono i giocatori queste o no come
funziona
al momento tu si
no marchetta finita volevo divertirmi
altre no quindi la versione incubo 6
young diventi cattivo siccome impegno
che io ho votato il capitolo 2 vediamo
se riusciamo a capirlo 1 allora votiamo
incubo
vediamo se riusciamo essere noi gli orsi
cattivi che bello ma
anche la storia è la stessa e così i
problemi cos'altro cambia oltre al fatto
che diventa uno un orsacchiotto malefico
se allora diceva chiama rossa io sei una
persona ancora non si è visto l'orso
tetti
scappa aiuto io
cosa c'è qui siamo
contro
bacon la versione incubo è anche un
pochino più pauroso perché è buio buio e
anche la musica
no che succede
il caso del miele mi sono bloccata
perché non era colate di con questa
posto tirargli addosso questo veramente
non appena arriva ora deve prima
sistemare penso vedi ha bisogno della
chiave inglese che si è aperto qualcosa
vedi la
bravo no magari puoi scavare un buco e
scappare
dove posso scavarlo e non lo so
me gigante 7 tg caratteri
beh almeno ora sono ignote b cerchiamo
caso credo è così piccolo medie gigante
perché io sono così piccolo vai pure
abbiamo
questo eccitante perché siamo mini
tenenti il verde restano anche
lentissimo va di qua va di qua possiamo
prendere qua
senza se prendo un giocatore
lui preso
[Musica]
eliminato è il grande tennis c'era un
nostro giocatore di
cattivissimi e io capisco se cimino
tutti i giocatori
come rumore erano già al mio mi ha dato
tutto per me siete milite di anita
arrivato coppia paura non c'è più
nessuno qua mi amo andare al capitolo 2
dai votata il capitolo 2 perché gli
altri capitoli iniziano solo se la
walther faccia se i giocatori li vota ma
sembra che tutti vogliono giocare del
118 semplice abbiamo forse riusciamo
andare al capitolo 2 detto sì facciamo
modalità normale no hanno votato
quest'anno dai aspetta aspetta
solo capo grizzly tre sono che cosa è
questo a posto ho bisogno di tornare a
casa viene accolta era quello di trovare
chiavi ok ma che sia tra potere che
carino qui c'è una chiave leghista solo
andiamo
dove è una pagina nera
devo trovare qualcosa di nero per
aprirla questa blu e blu a sé
passiamo ottimo che bello di un
villaggio in villaggio di ragazzo che
bello
questa perde però mettere quella no
questa tra grigia se
devo trovare la porta blu qua sotto
e bellissimo e la sorpresa è lasciato
con la chiave per prenderne un'altra mai
preso una green gialla non so di che
colore è questa deve daranno lui capisce
forse quella aperte notte russo bassa ma
rosso o arancione
forse quella ragione diamo sì forse sì
bravo ripari finora non ho visto teddy
credo sia questa non è questa
[Musica]
l'acqua che vi ho già fatto una vittima
operino
questo tipo e colore non piccone questa
la chiave nera nome nero
portarli il xk questo parco velocemente
non posso capire più velocemente questo
è il massimo della mia felicità poco ti
racconto che corre corre corre corre
questa è attenzione a poi dice che c'è
un orso di l'orso penso sia tesi che mi
sta inseguendo
aiuto ma dove sono gli altri giocatori
mi sembra che sorgerà un diritto mi sa
che non ci sono più di altri giocatori
l'unica c'è qualcuno qua che è stato
eliminato è troppo tardi
ok facciamo da spettatore almeno capiamo
che cosa dobbiamo fare
le due si sta nascondendo vedi se
nascosto senza aprire nessuna porta c'è
la chiave blu vi ha lasciato prima
perché la presa vediamo stessa qual è la
porta
questa la chiave che sono vito c'è un
altro giocatore si stanno parlando si
stanno scambiando dei consigli
neanche anche loro non sanno dove andare
o no mi sa che è troppo vicino ormai
un mese fa scappare nei testi ha preso
con la insomma alcun altro quindi lui è
riuscito a scappare ma dove doveva la
chiave blu vediamo se riesce a trovarla
ma mi sa che era qui la chiave blu che
destano era nera non mi ricordo bene non
siamo gli unici che non riuscivano a
trovare le fate
perché anche questo personaggio larius
porta giusto vediamo se c'è qualcun
altro no credo che ci è rimasto solo
ferito
guarda quanto inquietante questo
animatronici inizio e di
là preso o no non so dove siamo finiti
non so chi ha rapito lo stia questa sia
scritto forse il capitolo 4 corri corri
altre parole è un panda lui non è più un
orso vedi con lui
c'è un coccodrillo o
liquidi ma
mi sa che sei bloccata che se n'è andato
immagino che dobbiamo trovare le chiavi
anche poi
qualcuno sia stato sfracellato
ma se voleva chiave ok iniziamo a
cercare
l'attivissimo qua
verde acqua forse qua riuscirà a trovare
una via che vediamo
lasciate questa zona
una fatta
più preso
tutto perché mi sono fermata correre ma
alcune bagno
insomma pure tu
lascio di un po di privacy ok facciamo
da spettatori ma che così grande e le
qual è la madre e la moticea abbandonato
nel bruno vitolo adesso la presenza nel
porto capitolo quanto pare vuole
aiutarci risparmia con bene dietro la
porta noi
ripulita dai guai partirà
più tardi
non solo papà che ci manca solo da
provare il capitolo 3 kg ma cosa ho
capito
che disco di una morte tanto buona
volontà
sappiamo com'è fatto quel mondo di
giocattoli a tono
ecco la madre nostra madre pensavo che
saremmo tornati a casa invece
adesso premessa per tempo amico si è
rinchiusa
volendo recata
trovò un giocattolo e ce ne andremo ok
[Musica]
mamma dove sei
trovare che
mi sa che quello è l'orso tempi gigante
della vita nero tra auto però dobbiamo
trovare le chiavi
giocattoli sì forse devi trovare le
chiavi per poi trovare il giocattolo che
devi prendere mettiamo c'è un maltempo
ei mi hanno rubato
fighissima negozi di giocattoli hanno
aperto una porta cantarli quelle questi
giocatori di notte
magazzino a teheran dobbiamo trovare le
chiama filiera molto pettiniamo qua sono
i bagni se vediamo se c'è qualcosa non
sia proposta anche quasi ancora la
chiave
al centro i suoi passi
9 di ancora l'infermo per fortuna questo
che possiamo mettiamoci di vita ci vuole
poi quella chiamata era capito guarda
quasi un altro tendi chiude nella
confezione
danza lorca ma neanche accorte era lì
vicino come di arrivato subito mandiamo
qualche altro giocatore più bravo di noi
allora con le stesse nascondendo venga
presso la chiave dorata bartali se un
robot
e nel magazzino non è questo però
tipo la fabbrica dei giocattoli
qualcuno è stata sfracellato di hodeida
morti premier ha preso ok vediamo un
altro giocatore
senza occhi quindi l'orso gigante ancora
lì ce n'è un altro un prodotto scappando
dal bagno
no ha cambiato idea non può entrare uno
sveglio di noi speriamo che ce la faccia
e con orson derby è noto ma chi sta
facendo con martello queste di scappare
un dannato col martello ha tutto
però gli manca la chiave
muro
poverino bene perché erano tutti i
capitoli di teddy anche per noi stiamo
delle piazze siamo riusciti a completare
neo che ha una super divertente vi
lasciamo ora qualcosa che puoi cliccare
provvedere i nostri altri video caricato
su quella che preferite buona visione